en esta ocasión quiero que obtengamos un
poco más de práctica resolviendo algunas
ecuaciones exponenciales y aquí tengo
dos ecuaciones exponenciales diferentes
y como siempre te pido que pausas el
vídeo y veas si en ámbas ecuaciones
puedes obtener el valor de x resuelve lo
para x
ok primero vamos a resolver esta de aquí
y como podrás haberte dado cuenta en
ambos lados de la ecuación tengo bases
distintas lo que quiere decir que
estaría muy bien que tuviéramos la misma
base pero como puedes ver 32 no es una
potencia de 8 o al menos no es una
potencia entera de 8 pero ambas son
potencias de 2 por lo tanto puedo
escribir a este 32 como 2 elevado a la
quinta potencia como 2 elevado a la
quinta potencia y puedo escribir a este
8 como 2 elevado a la tercera potencia
estás de acuerdo y ya con esto puedo
reescribir
esta ecuación de la siguiente manera me
va a quedar como 2 elevado a la quinta
potencia lo cual es 32 2 elevado a la
quinta potencia esto a su vez elevado a
la potencia x sobre 3
y sobre 3 esto me va a quedar
exactamente igual que bueno y tengo 2
elevado al cubo 2 elevado al cubo esto a
su vez elevado a la potencia x menos 12
no olvidemos esta potencia que tengo
aquí x menos 12 y ahora se elevó algo a
una cierta potencia y después lo elevó a
otra cierta potencia entonces
simplemente puedo multiplicar estos
exponentes entonces del lado izquierdo
se multiplicó estos dos que me va a
quedar bueno me va a quedar 2 elevado a
que potencia
bueno 5 por x sobre 3 es lo mismo que es
5x sobre 3 déjame ponerlo 5 x sobre 3 lo
único que estoy haciendo es multiplicar
5 por x sobre 3 y bueno eso es del lado
izquierdo del lado derecho que me va a
quedar me va a quedar 2 elevado a que
potencia
bueno pues voy a multiplicar 3
por equis y después tres por menos doce
distribuyendo la multiplicación de 3 por
x 12 y eso va a ser lo mismo que 2
elevado a la 3x menos 36 de lujo lo
único que hice fue multiplicar las
potencias y ahora observa que ya tenemos
la misma base y si ya tenemos la misma
base eso quiere decir que este exponente
tiene que ser exactamente igual a este
otro exponente para que esta ecuación se
cumpla es decir 5x sobre 3 tiene que ser
igual a 3 x menos 36 y así vamos a poder
resolver para x déjame escribirlo eso
quiere decir que 5x sobre 3 esto tiene
que ser igual a 3 x menos 36 bien ya
tenemos una ecuación muy sencilla de
resolver así que qué te parece
multiplicamos todo por 3 voy a
multiplicar todo por 3 de este lado y de
este otro lado también voy a multiplicar
todo por 3 así que este 3 y este 3 se
van y me queda simple y sencillamente
que 5x es igual a 9 x 9 x menos 36 por 3
es 108 de lujo y ahora voy a restar de
ambos lados de esta ecuación 9 x y me va
a quedar lo siguiente 5 x 9 x es lo
mismo que menos 4x y de este lado
solamente me voy a quedar con menos 108
de lujo y ahora bajemos la pantalla para
obtener el valor de x y quién va a ser
bueno pues vamos a dividir todo entre
menos 4 todo entre menos 4 y que voy a
obtener estos dos se van y me queda que
x es igual a 184 es lo mismo que ven
7 de lujo entonces x toma el valor de 27
esa es mi respuesta y si tú tomas esa
respuesta y la sustituye es justo acá
arriba obtendrías esta igualdad que
tengo aquí 32 elevado a la 27 entre 3
bueno 27 entre 3 es lo mismo que 932
elevado a la potencia 9 es exactamente
lo mismo que 8 elevado a la potencia 27
menos 12 es decir 8 elevado a la
potencia 15 en fin eso es solamente para
divertirnos un poco la respuesta es que
x es igual a 27 y entonces vamos a hacer
el siguiente y bueno este ejercicio se
ve más interesante porque fíjate que
tenemos expresiones racionales y además
tenemos una exponencial arriba y una
exponencial abajo y por todos lados así
que bueno lo primero que se me ocurre y
lo primero que quiero hacer es pasar
este 25 en términos de la base que vamos
a usar que es
y bueno sabemos que 25 es lo mismo que 5
al cuadrado entonces esto de aquí que me
va a quedar me va a quedar que 5 elevado
a la 4 x más 3 esto dividido entre y en
lugar de 25 voy a escribir 5 el de pago
al cuadrado y esto a su vez está elevado
a la potencia 9 x 9 menos x y bueno esto
va a ser igual a 5 elevado a la 2 x más
5 de lugo y bueno cuánto va a ser 5
elevado al cuadrado esto a su vez
elevado a la 9 - x
bueno pues los exponentes se multiplican
así que arriba me va a quedar 5 elevado
a la 4x
3 y en la parte de abajo estos dos se
van a multiplicar y obtengo lo siguiente
5 elevado a la potencia 2 por 9 es 18 y
2 por menos x es menos 2x estás de
acuerdo lo que hice fue multiplicar
estas dos potencias y bueno del lado
derecho
me quedan 5 elevado a la 2 x más 5 muy
bien y bueno como pueden resolver esto
se me ocurren varias maneras una de
ellas es decir voy a multiplicar todo
por esta parte de abajo es decir voy a
multiplicar todo por 5 elevado a las 18
menos 2x y esa sería una manera de
hacerlo o podemos decir hey aquí tengo 5
elevado a una cierta potencia entre 5
elevado a otra cierta potencia esto va a
ser lo mismo que cinco elevado a la
diferencia de las potencias simplemente
puedo restarle esta potencia de azul a
esta potencia de amarillo
del lado izquierdo que me va a quedar me
va a quedar 5 elevado a la potencia 4x +
3 ya esto le vamos a quitar este
exponente de abajo - y bueno déjame
ponerlo con su respectivo color menos 18
menos 2
cuidado este menos afecta a todo este
paréntesis y bueno eso va a ser igual a
5 elevado a las 2 x más 5 y ahora
podemos simplificar un poco todo esto
para eso déjenme bajar un poco la
pantalla y ahora observa lo siguiente
como ya tenemos la misma base entonces
ahora sí podemos decir que esto va a ser
exactamente igual a esto otro así que
vamos a simplificarlo lo voy a hacer con
este color 4 x + 3 menos 18 ya estoy
multiplicando por este menos menos por
18 me queda menos 18 y menos por menos 2
x eso es más 2 x
esto va a ser igual a 2x
+ 5 y bueno hay un montón de formas para
resolver esto y una de ellas es restar
2x de ambos lados de esta ecuación por
lo tanto se van a eliminar este de aquí
y este de aquí y bueno lo que también se
me ocurre es restar a 5 de ambos lados
de esta ecuación voy a restar 5 de este
lado y también de éste la vamos a
hacerlo así que que me queda muy bien me
estoy saltando algunos pasos pero estoy
seguro que ya estás muy familiarizado
con ecuaciones lineales así que vamos a
hacerlo un poco más rápido 4x me va a
quedar 4x y después 3 positivo menos 18
eso es lo mismo que menos 15 3 - 18 es
menos 15 menos 5 es menos 20 y bueno de
este lado solamente me queda 0 de lujo y
después si sumó 20 de ambos lados de
esta ecuación me va a quedar que 4x es
lo mismo que 20 y se habrá dividido
partes entre 4 entre 4 voy a obtener que
x x va a ser igual a 20 entre 4 lo cual
es 5 y ya está ya tengo aquí la solución
de este segundo ejercicio